my reptile brain is telling me that this
thing is alive and then my intellect
tells me no I know it's just a piece of
plastic and some software we've stumbled
upon something really super interesting
actually
this is Ferhat a promising stab at
trying to make mechanical creatures and
computer interfaces appear and act more
like humans hi my name is Ashley hello
Ashley nice to meet you I am a socially
intelligent robot it's nice to meet you
as well
nice shirt thank you we want to build a
system that can interact very fluently
with humans understand their social
signals their emotions their attention
States there's a phenomenon known as the
uncanny valley
it's that queasy feeling you get when a
robot or computer interface looks real
but not real enough the brains behind
Ferhat these two hardcore academics
think they're on their way to solving
that problem and making robots less
nauseating we come from a background of
human human communications on how humans
interact with each other is the social
layer that is on top of the typical AI
if they can push the technology forward
Ferhat could end up as the face of Siri
or Amazon's Alexa it might keep lonely
people company do you think I look good
or be the thing you yell at when
checking in for a flight at the airport
can you walk us through each little
piece that is main piece here it's gonna
happen a wig and a skull and a mask as
far as robots go fur hats design is
really simple it's as easy as taking
your mask on and off and then the mask
is magnetically attached so you can
unplug the mask and then you can attach
the different masks in front first out
then it needs to be calibrated so that
you can get the right yeah I do want to
see the alien baby what did you say
there is a facial animation system you
know like the ones you have in games an
animated movie
yeah so it's all software based and then
we use a micro projector to project that
animation onto a master you get very
accurate eye movement gestures facial
expressions lip animation I can look
like a woman and sound like a woman like
an avatar
that's flowers but I think the world has
been really waiting for robots at home
to interact with Tokyo to see them in a
human natural habitat where we don't see
any robots at the moment one day
Ferhat might read bedtime stories to
your kid I'd say it's at the nightmare
stage of that journey but the product
has gone on sale for use by universities
which are busy tweaking it to ensure
sweet dreams in the years to come you're
boring why would you say that to me you
would look strange or to sling insults
and handsome TV hosts how about a beer